на цьому подвір'ї не буває тихо родина
дзусів - це 12 осіб
мама Наталія тато Юрій десятеро діток і
дві собаки
разом Вони пережили найстрашніші дні
війни Росії проти України
Цей будинок багатодітна родина
заселилася 22 лютого за два дні до
вторгнення РФ коли придбали Цей будинок
то звичайно ми мріяли були дуже щасливі
від того що у нас багато простору власне
будинок тому що ми прожили все життя в
квартирі але от Ну так склалося що
буквально з перших днів перебування тут
от у нас постійні були такі перешкоди
село Демидів у якому проживає родина у
перші дні наступу РФ опинилося в
окупації а невдовзі у воді
Наприкінці лютого 2022 ЗСУ підірвали
тутешню дамбу щоби зупинити наступ
росіян цілий досі частково залишається
підтопленим тут все було затоплено в нас
якраз от вода підійшла під двір і було
затоплені і насосна станція все було Ми
дуже переживали що залишилося взагалі
без води без ну без питної
на той момент у родині було 9 дітей 5
біологічних та четверо всиновлених вони
боялися дуже сильно боялися росіяни
приходили вони постійно перевіряли і не
можна було нікуди вийти крім постійної
небезпеки з боку російських військових
додалися й побутові проблеми проживання
в новому будинку одразу перетворилося на
виживання на перший день В нас зникла
зникло світло тобто зникла вода вона
залишався газ до 8 березня 8 березня вже
зник і газ а 7 березня якраз до нас
зайшли вже в будинок і якраз оце було ну
стартовою точкою Після якої ми вирішили
що все-таки ми будемо йти наступного ж
дня пані Наталія разом із дітьми пішки
тікали з окупованого Демидова
наймолодшій Ксенії на той момент було
лише три роки Ну ми пішки пройшли десь з
кілометрів в 5 Да ми взяли рюкзачки всі
були там тільки
шмато там якісь там спідня білизна якісь
там шкарпетки і все в мене в голові весь
час така думка тікай тікай тікай тікать
І от вона просто Ну насправді Було дуже
страшно тому що ти розумієш що ти
захистити дітей не можеш і нічого Ну
нічого зробити не можеш у нас підвалу
нема пані Наталія разом із дітьми
знайшла тимчасовий прихисток у Німеччині
у Німеччині ми жили в альденштайні
приймали нас там дуже чудово ви знаєте
от в мене завжди була думка написати
навіть подяку тому що кожного ранку ми
то до нас постійно хтось стукав двері то
нам принесли мед потім якась пані
приносить нам стіну такий чудові торти
пироги які там Ну були дуже-дуже надто
смачні навіть там сусіди теж українці
вони приходили до нас ласувати цим всім
потім в нас запрошувала до себе Графиня
з Німеччини теж Ми їздили в сусідній в
сусідній місто ну взагалі все було
Звичайно чудово Але все рівно хочеться
додому тому у червні торік пані Ната Лія
з дітьми повернулася в демиді будинок
придбаний для щасливого життя і досі
посічений уламками від російських
снарядів це у нас та сторона
з якої в принципі були всі перельоти всі
Осколки
але щастя у цей будинок все-таки прийшло
батьки маленького дані зникли за
невідомих обставин восени Минулого року
родина дзусів погодилася прихистити
немовля так місяць тому в подружжя
з'явилася десята дитина
запропонували його взяти в родину ми
погодились Даня в нас уже місяць
знаходиться в принципі зараз Ми
займаємося його обстеженням реабілітацію
були переживання стосовно того що він
там спати не буде але ну взагалі просто
Таке враження що він у нас був завжди Та
це не єдине поповнення в родині джусєв
узимку сім'я прихистила пса якого
вдалося врятувати із бахмута жужей досі
здригається від вибухів але поступово
звикає до нормального життя вона під час
Першої таких тривоги вибух і вона ночью
підскакує ночная гавкать бігає по дому
майже і
гавкала бігала могла знайти собі тупо
місця і надавала нікому спати
багатодітну родину підтримують не лише
українські а іноземні волонтери у
березні цього року у гості додзусів
приїжджав британський актор і посол
доброї волі юнісеф Орландо Блум це
прапор який у мене в усіх ще спочатку
нашої війни і коли Орландо Блум заходив
Він кинув таку пропозицію підписати
прапор на згадку він підписав з любов'ю
та респектом до нашої родини візит
актора став справжньою несподіванкою для
багатодітної родини замість запланованих
30 хвилин Орландо Блум провів у цьому
будинку понад дві години час провели
супер Ми порозмовляли про його кар'єру
про взагалі наш стан він запитав як ми
себе почуваємо під час війни Ну в
принципі все пройшло більш-менш якщо
чесно думала буде якось нема про що
поговорити а якось тема дуже так гарно
зайшла і поговорили із малечею пограли і
з нами Так що все взагалі дуже супер і
Дякуємо за це що приїхав взагалі до нас
разом із сім'єю поступово розростається
й будинок пані Наталія з чоловіком
взялися добудовувати нові кімнати адже
мріють щоби у кожної дитини було
вдосталь особистого простору а
найголовніше мирне небо над головою це